And now the old scoutmaster:
I'm Dean Amader. and here's another weather fun fact from ScoutmasterCGcom.
After extensive study, it's been determined that the chance of precipitation increases
in inverse proportion to the proximity of rain year.
Research also shows that there's a direct relationship between the probability of precipitation
and the number of moisture-sensitive items exposed to the elements.
Statistics indicate that the probability these items will be put away before precipitation begins
is in inverse proportion to their monetary value.
Researchers have published a statistical table called the picnic table
and, in practical terms, a loaf of bread left on a picnic table increases the probability
of precipitation by 20%,
While a digital camera left on the same table increases the probability of precipitation
by 60%.
I'm Dean Amader.
Thank you for this.
Well, thank you there, Deena.
I'm always trying to bring you the most up-to-date, current research and useful information.
I hope that helped.
Hey, this is podcast number 188..
Well, welcome back to the Scoutmaster Podcast.
This is Clark Green.
Hey, have you been over to the blog this week?
Go to ScoutmasterCGcom.
This past week we included a video review of Tomahawks
and a little information about Tomahawk throwing.
You want to make sure to check that out?
That's also at our YouTube channel.
Our next Scout Circle is Sunday, October 13th, between 9 and 10 pm
Eastern Standard Time.
Our guest is going to be Joe Jacaruso from gossamergearcom,
And we're going to be talking about backpacking and scouts-
Not just backpacking in general and backpacking gear and things like that.
but how do you take a group of scouts out backpacking?
You're going to find out that Joe is a very experienced scouter
and he's led many scouts through many, many miles of backpacking trips.
So tune in on Sunday, October 13th between 9 and 10 pm
Eastern Standard Time at scoutsircleorg.
You'll be able to watch the presentation
and ask Joe the questions that you have about scouts and backpacking
In this week's podcast in just a moment, in Scout MasterChip,
in seven minutes or less, we're going to be discussing
five patrol method fundamentals
And we've got some answers to email questions
and that's going to take up the rest of the podcast.
So let's get started, shall we?
Scout MasterChip in seven minutes or less?
In 1920, Baden Powell wrote a booklet called
Aged Scout MasterChip
And within that booklet he lays out these five
fundamental things for applying the patrol method.
They're just as true now as they were the day that he wrote them,
So let's take a look at them.
The first is the formation of patrols.
Now Baden Powell said six to eight,
and that's still a pretty good rule of thumb.
We scouts, although, have fallen into the habit
of assigning scouts to patrols according to our idea
of what best serves our concerns,
Almost to the exclusion of the scouts' own choice.
Scouts ought to choose their patrol,
And we're going to talk a little bit more about that
in one of the email answers that's coming up in this podcast.
The second fundamental is real free-handed responsibility,
And that's exactly the way Baden Powell put it:
Free-handed responsibility.
Patrol leaders have to have actual responsibility.
They have to be allowed to think and plan for their patrol.
This is a delicate business.
Too much training and mentoring and oversight from adults
is going to smother the flame of initiative
that we want to see in our patrol leaders.
Feed that fire slowly.
Partial responsibility only brings partial results.
Number three is that patrols are independent, distinct
and autonomous.
They have to stand on their own.
They need their own identity.
That's why we have a patrol name and a patrol flag,
a patrol yell and all that kind of great stuff.
Now this extends to every aspect of the program.
When they're camping together,
each patrol has their own area, their own food,
their own leadership and you know,
they can follow their own program
Elsewhere. in his writings Baden Powell,
when asked if patrols could go camping together,
said that he was a little skeptical about the idea
because it would tend to make scouts
into one big, giant group to be administered.
He said that if a couple of patrols went camping together
well, he wouldn't necessarily say that it was a bad idea,
but he'd want them to be at least a quarter mile apart.
In practical terms we're not going to be able to do that
in most of the places that we go camping.
But giving patrols their own distinct area,
letting them decide what they're going to eat
and go out and buy the food and prepare it for themselves,
and exercising their own leadership, their own oversight
and even their own program during campouts, is a great idea.
The fourth fundamental of the patrol method
is emulation and competition between patrols.
Spirited good nature competition amongst patrols
helps that patrol spirit grow and flourish.
Games and contests among patrols build individual
as well as group character, as scouts realize
that their individual contribution means something
that it adds to his patrol's honor and spirit.
And the fifth fundamental of the patrol method
is the Patrol Leaders Council.
The tone of everything the patrol does
is set by the Patrol Leaders Council,
exercising real authority and decision-making power
in choosing and preparing for activities.
Now, naturally, they're making all those decisions
and making all those plans in the context
of the goals of scouting.
We work with them to understand what those goals
and what that context is and then we get them moving.
Is it really that simple?
If you just follow those five fundamentals,
do you have the patrol method?
Yeah, it's really that simple.
but a lot of things in life are simple
but they take a lot of study and application
and practice to master right
Swinging a hammer or a golf club.
I can show you how to do that
and you can do that in 20 seconds.
That's going to take a little while.
If we begin with those five fundamentals
and we stick to them,
we're going to see the patrol method
do exactly what it was intended to do
and that is to achieve the aims of scouting.
Write me a letter,
Send it by name.
Email. that is folks.
And here's an answer to one of your emails.
So I got this email from Robert
and Robert said: first, let me say thank you
for the emails that I've subscribed to,
Love reading them for ideas and suggestions.
I'm a scout master and I've taken over
just a few months ago
I'm a bit younger, I'm 30 years old.
I don't have a child in the troop,
but my nephew is a member.
I'm an Eagle Scout and I was asked by the committee
to step in and be the scout master
and help out with our troop.
We have about 20 active scouts.
Prior to my becoming scout master,
siblings were permitted on campouts
and I really don't approve of it-
Both brothers and sisters, older and younger.
then the scouts come along
and they really become a distraction
for the scouts and the adult leaders,
as well as all the other issues and concerns
you may imagine arise.
When I talk about this, I'm getting a lot of pushback.
People involved with the troop right now
argue that scouting is a family activity.
I'd like to hear your thoughts on this.
Well, Robert, first of all,
congratulations for taking on the scout master job.
Of course, the next step,
whether you're an Eagle Scout or not,
is getting yourself trained.
Go to training and that way
you're going to have the answers
to these questions before they're asked.
When a scout troop goes camping,
it's not family camping.
I'm aware that some troops conduct a special camp out
where family members are invited
once a year or so.
but scout camping is about
scouts camping with their patrol
Full stop.
What you describe as not scouting.
It's not even remotely like no little brothers and sisters
or unregistered big brothers and sisters
or unregistered parents,
unless they're required to meet
youth protection guidelines,
Then you only need one
Scouts work with and share tents with
the other scouts in their patrol,
Not anybody else.
If we aren't doing this,
we aren't really doing scouting.
You were chosen to serve as a scout master,
so it's up to you to be a scout master,
not a family camping coordinator.
When you're in your shoes,
I would tell- not ask,
but tell- the troop committee
that you're going to take only scouts
and registered adult leaders
on the next camping trip
because you'd like to actually do scouting.
Explain that there is simply no provision
anywhere in your training
for taking anyone other than that.
Now they're going to push back
and when they push back,
explain that they've asked you to be a scout master.
in order for you to be the scout master,
You're going to be able to take a scout master
program according to your knowledge and training
and you're going to expect their support
when you do so.
Bring along a scout master handbook
and the scout handbook and ask the committee
to find where it says that scouting
is a family camping program.
They're not going to be able to find it
because it's not there.
Honestly, Robert, if they won't support you in this,
tell them it's time to find another scout master.
If things are this far off the rails
and the committee is unwilling to change
what we're being able to accomplish
much of what a scout master is charged with doing-
I also heard from Derek
and he says: I'm a scout master
with less than a year under my belt
and I'm faced with a good problem.
We're growing. We currently have four patrols
and we anticipate that we'll get
another seven scouts
when we blows crossover in February.
That would mean a fifth patrol.
Currently we have one first year patrol
and two second year patrols
and one patrol made up of the remaining older boys.
The third patrol is usually
woefully understaffed during outings
as those scouts are either committed to other obligations
or working. I think the patrols
need to be reworked a bit,
but I don't want to break up any close friends
or turn patrols into popularity contests.
What I'm considering is splitting up the oldest patrol
and putting those scouts into the other three patrols.
Based on your experience,
is this a good idea or a bad idea,
or maybe there's a better way?
I must admit I haven't asked the scouts yet,
but I would anticipate that the older boys
would not really want to be split up.
I should add that there is a two year age difference
between the older boy patrol
and the next oldest patrol.
Plus, I really like the idea of keeping scouts together
in their own patrol,
for the first year at least.
Any suggestions?
Well, Derek, I want to answer your question
by asking a few other questions.
We have to think about these things.
Why are boys in scouting?
Why do we have patrols?
Are patrols just so that we have an efficient system
to gauge scouts, or is it something more than that?
Does what a scout thinks
is a quote-unquote good patrol
look different to him
than it would look to an adult?
Boys are scouts because their friends are involved.
If they don't get to work with their friends,
they're not very interested in scouts.
We have patrols
because basically, there's no scouting
without them.
99% of the aims of scouting
are met in the context of the patrol.
Scouts working together
encounter all kinds of challenges
and they learn all kinds of things.
When they go camping, they go by patrol.
At meetings, they're preparing to go camping
by patrol. Everything in scouting
is about the patrol.
Once you understand this,
you'll agree that scouts ought to be able
to freely choose their patrol.
They know who they get along with
and who their friends are.
To understand how your scouts are going to view
you stepping in to make changes
to their patrols, imagine
the opportunity to evaluate your troop
and the one next door.
After studying both troops,
I'm going to make a few changes
to optimize the combination of adult volunteers.
Both troops have adults
with differing levels of experience.
I'm going to change some of them around
so that both of them have equally experienced adults.
Some adults in each troop
have a busy schedule
and that means they can't be there at times,
and that leaves things woefully understaffed.
I'm going to need to change them around, too,
to even things out.
Thinking about it, it's really a kind of a poor use of resources
for you to have 20 scouts
and the other troop to have 40 scouts.
so I'm going to even that out too,
so that both troops have 30 scouts,
And I need to make some changes
to see that we have a consistent
adult to scout ratio.
Your troop has 10 assistant scout masters,
but it only needs 7,
and so 3 need to go to the other troop.
Finally, I'll be assigning
the weeblows crossing over this spring
between the two troops.
I mean, it's only fair right, After all.
we don't want this to be
some kind of popularity contest.
So would you appreciate it if I made those changes?
Of course not,
Even though they make perfect sense on paper.
I'm taking away your friends, I'm breaking up your team,
I'm telling your scouts
who they ought to be going scouting with.
When we fix patrols,
when we try to even out numbers
and ranks and ages and experience,
we're usually breaking up friends and teams.
Scouts find this just as disheartening
as you or I would
if I made the changes in the scenario
I imagined just a moment ago.
Scouts really ought to be able
to choose their own patrols.
Let me give you an example of why that works.
About a year ago, when something went wrong
in our troop, it usually led back to three
of our scouts that we had dubbed
the terrible trio.
Our senior patrol leader
decided that he was going to break them up
and put them in different patrols,
but it didn't work.
No matter what patrol they were in,
the terrible trio were fast friends
and they gravitated to each other
at meetings and at outings.
This kind of thing caused their patrol leaders
no end of aggravation.
They were always chasing them down
and trying to figure out where they were
and making them be part of the patrol.
The next senior patrol leader decided
that if these guys wanted to be together
it was going to be useless to fight with them,
so we let them form their own patrol.
Our scouts wanted to be in that patrol,
so for a few months there we had a patrol
of three scouts.
Once these three friends were together,
they all showed up at just about
every meeting and every camp out,
and soon they grew
from being the terrible trio
to becoming a competent, well-behaved patrol.
When it comes to patrols,
let the scouts choose,
accept their choices
and help them solve any problems
that their choices might create.
What's not nice and neat?
but scouting is about
the processes involved
in making choices
and the alchemy of working together
with your peers to meet challenges
and solve problems.
Talk to your senior patrol leader,
ask him some questions.
ask him if he thinks the patrols
are set up the right way
or if he would change anything.
how is he going to incorporate
the new scouts that are coming into the troop,
as he's going to make.
you may end up with patrols of 10 or 12,
or patrols of 3 and 4
and everything in between.
you may have patrols with mixed ages
or all the same age.
it may look efficient or messy
and you'll wonder if it's a mistake.
but be patient,
work with the patrol leaders council
and watch what happens.
it'll take some practice and some patience,
but soon you'll see that those patrols
are full of happy, advancing scouts
having the time of their lives.
and finally, I found this email in my inbox
and I'm going to withhold
the name on this one.
it said this:
I am a new assistant scout master in my first year.
I followed the blog and the podcast
since I started and I appreciate the advice.
after going through training and listening to you,
I've arrived at the conclusion
that our troop is led
by adults too much.
our scout master is a great guy.
he's a born leader
and genuinely cares about scouting,
but he just doesn't seem to be able
to help himself.
he hovers over the scouts at troop meetings
and he frequently interrupts them.
instead of scouts making announcements
at the troop meetings, it's always the adults.
at courts of honor, the adult leaders
stand around the boys at the front of the room
and hover over them and say things like:
by the end of this, the scouts
may just get it right.
troop meetings are lecture classes presented
by adults, and the adults plan all the outings.
I'm really not sure what to do.
our troop has a lot of history,
it's very active and we have a lot of great
scouts and families involved.
I want to support the scout master,
but I'm having a hard time.
at first I thought I would just
wait around and slowly
influence, giving the troop back to the
scouts, but now that my concerns
are getting the better of me,
do you have any advice?
well, I've always got some advice
right
first. if that's the situation
you find yourself in, you're not alone.
I get a fair number of emails just
like this. you know
we have a great troop with a long history
and wonderful people. but
and then we have a problem.
based on years of
observation of literally hundreds
of troops and the emails
that I get,
I guess I would safely estimate that
about 40 to 50 percent of scout
troops are led by a 40 year
old senior patrol leader that calls himself
a scout master.
now, this is nothing new.
Baden Powell was combating this
propensity of adults to take over
from the day he founded the movement.
the scouts in these troops
are happy,
they're fine, they do a lot of great stuff,
they advance and rank
and they get a lot of scouting. despite
the way the troop has run,
it's difficult to advise you on what
to do about this particular issue
because as an assistant scout master,
you aren't really in a position to make any changes.
hoping you can slowly
influence this change,
I think that's an admirable thought,
but it's not likely.
as you said, this scout master just can't
help himself, and that's probably because
he's not even aware that there's
any kind of a problem.
if, on the one hand, he's really committed to youth leadership
and applying the patrol method,
well, that's one thing.
on the other hand, if he's been around for a few years,
he's got this all figured out
well, that's indefinitely another.
what will happen eventually is you're going to have
to bring your concerns to the scout master,
and I know some scout masters
are going to be more approachable than others.
but if you go to him and you say
something like I'm new here,
but there are some things I think we're missing,
would you be willing to discuss some of this
and think about how we could change things.
this can be a little bit of a gamble,
but I'd leave it up to you
to figure out if it's a good idea or not.
if the scout master doesn't want to change,
you know, your face will
living the way things are now
or finding a new troop that's more to your liking.
now that sounds a little dramatic,
but it really comes down to that.
more importantly, it comes down to
your son. is he happy?
from his perspective,
this is about camping with his friends.
would your actions adversely affect that?
if adults start arguing,
scouts lose.
but if you do things in the right spirit,
you'll avoid arguments.
if you bring this up and the answer is no,
you're going to pretty much have to
accept the answer
or change troops.
if you keep hammering away at it,
you're going to be branded a troublemaker
and that's going to affect your son.
you know, sometimes we change jobs
and friends and churches
and even spouses, I mean-
until we find the right fit.
scouting is kind of the same way.
we calculate the losses and benefits
of the change that we make
and we may conclude that we're better off accepting
things that rankle us
rather than changing our situation.
sometimes we can work
towards making things better,
but it's heavy lifting if you aren't in charge.
in that case, you need a little serenity
to change what you can
and accept what you can.
I hope that helps.
if you have a question for me,
send it to clark at scoutmastercgcom.
c-l-a-r-k-e.
scoutmastercgcom.
thanks for listening.
Thanks for listening. here's how to keep in touch.
Read the Scoutmaster blog at scoutmastercgcom and you can subscribe to receive updates to
the blog by email. by the way,
You can subscribe to this podcast, the Scoutmaster podcast, on iTunes and when you do leave a
comment or review or a rating, you can also access the podcast on your mobile device through
Stitcher Smart Radio, and you can get details about how to make that happen at Stitchercom.
You can experience the wonders of scoutmastercgcom through the vast panorama of social media outlets.
Follow us at Scoutmaster blog on Facebook, tweet ScoutmasterCG on Twitter and watch us
at ScoutmasterCG on YouTube.
For admins to the exclusive ScoutmasterCG circle, search for us on Google+.
Once again, if none of that works for you, you can always email me. zoom into the late
90s and send me an email at clarkclarkeatscoutmastercgcom.
The Scoutmaster blog and the Scoutmaster podcast are not official publications of the
Boy Scouts of America, nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
Hey, it's just me talking into a microphone, trying to lend a hand to scout leaders and
have a little bit of fun along the way. and speaking of fun, here is our founder, Sir
Robert Baden Powell.
Sir Robert,
Good luck to you and good camping.
Why? thank you, sir, until next time.